okay
foreign
Jerry
okay I got it now now that you've told
me I got it now very good good morning
if
I'll call a finance committee to order
and first on our schedule we have the
department of administrative Services I
see the commissioner and his able staff
here to explain the handout that uh Mr
Ripple has just passed out
welcome
whatever works
let's try that again I'm Charlie
arlinghaus I'm the commission of
administrative services and
technologically challenged apparently
you are Cassie Keenum the Deputy
Commissioner
I'm Sheri Rockford and I'm the assistant
commissioner
so there we go all three of us here for
you
um I have a handout to sort of guide our
discussion based on what I think you
wanted to hear based on uh rumors and
innuendos about what went on and was
said in meetings and that you had
interest in
um but uh if you look at page two it's
sort of a table of contents I'm going to
talk about governance collective
bargaining inflation the classification
system reforming the system Recruitment
and hiring
I'm going to start on page three talking
about the governance system
the executive branch job classification
system and employee compensation think
of it as the civil service system I try
to explain this to people because we use
a lot of terms that people don't
necessarily understand
what do you mean what's the
classification system what is that what
is that thing and it you know I don't
want to get into a discussion of the
obsession nation of James Garfield and
the creation of a merit system and and
Social Security Act amendments from the
from the 30s but
um we're governed by state and federal
law administrative rules collective
bargaining agreement between the state
and 14 different unions which is more
than it used to be and it seems like
it's growing all the time there's
probably one or two people here who
remember back when there were something
like two unions as opposed to 14.
um probably not not that many people
here who remember that but the key rsas
in case anyone wants to look at them RSA
21i which is the admin Services RSA
section 42 talks about division of
personnel establishing a job
classification system
273a is a public Labor Relations law uh
collective bargaining law which dates to
1975 as some I think some people know
about what's uh what's bargained
and then there's some Provisions in RSA
99 about the adjustments of salaries is
primarily about classified positions on
classifying their governed in a slightly
different way
turning to page four I want to talk
about collective bargaining agreements
um there's a lot of collective
bargaining agreements there are 14
different collective bargaining
agreements the unions are bargained with
both together and separately and to give
you an a sense of the balkanization of
the process
I think when I started there were nine
and now there are 14 and you know I
don't know exactly the time frame but go
back maybe 10 years number four go back
20 years and there were two or three
um it's not just the sca it's a whole
bunch of different unions so today the
governor and the 14 unions have
tentatively agreed to an across the
board 10 Cola with uh two percent uh the
year after and there are other
provisions of that agreement but those
are the two that I think you're most
interested in talking about there have
been some discussion about can the
legislature change the negotiated Union
contracts the answer that is no
um and I have a little thumbs up and
thumbs down here to say that your your
role is functionally to say yes or no
you funded or you don't fund it so to
speak it's a it's an agreement between
the governor on one hand and the unions
on the other I had a question about the
joint committee on employee relations
which I was on years ago and as far as I
know I've talked with people that should
have been on it last December when this
some of this negotiation was going on I
don't believe that committee has met on
this contract I'm not I'm not aware that
they have
um
and I think I would be aware that they
had because the person who would have
come brief you works for me so um
they have not and historically they
haven't the history of that history of
that agreement is the legislature
involving itself in in the process and
updating itself on what's going on in
theory telling the the bargaining team
the governor's bargaining team if you
will what uh what they wished would be
negotiated historically it's very rare
that that group has ever met
um
my experience was we met on it years ago
on some facet and all we were told at
the time was you can say yes or no
and we said no then we negotiated and
took out the part we disliked
and we were happy that that sounds right
and I'm I'm glad that I'm glad that
that's the committee that you ended up
happy as a result of That's So Rare
these days
um it's certainly not usually my
experience but um
that group is typically more involved in
in years when the legislature and the
governor are in different parties for
example I think it was it was somewhat
active when Governor Hassan was governor
in the legislature was a Republican and
it was somewhat active in in you know
1920 when the reverse situation existed
Republican Governor Democratic
legislature well the experience was
after we had
exercised some control over the
over the budget
subsequently the Democrats removed the
committee
well I think it's come back and then
when the Republicans took over we
brought it back but as far as I know I
don't think it's met to get involved in
any of the negotiations since the
historic ups and downs I'd have to look
at they're often involved when there's a
fact-finding let's say that let's say
the unions and the governor don't reach
an agreement in our fact-finding reports
I know there were hearings in in
I'm going to say 2019 with regard to
fact finder reports and and that
occasionally comes up so uh one of the
questions uh in related to the
bargaining agreement is how much has
inflation eroded wages and yes we have
another question oh I'm sorry yes
hello good morning good to see you so on
page there's no page numbers the one
regarding collective bargaining
agreements right yes when you use the
term tentatively agreed can you be more
explicit the
um
the agreement between a governor and a
governor and a union is is uh you know
sometimes hear the shorthand oeta that
and what what it means is that there's a
tentative agreement between the two
bodies um they write a formal they write
a formal document that document becomes
effective with the with the funding of
the cost items
um by the legislature so so tentative
agreement is a is a is a term of Art in
collective bargaining and it just
suggests it's not effective the the
agreement is not effective until after
the sexual act yeah so
back to right definitions matter right
if there is a tentative agreement in
place and the legislature doesn't fund
it does that then kick it back to a
review of that agreement just what
happens in a flowchart process wise
um if you don't fund the agreement is
rejected and collective bargaining would
have to either begin again or be in hold
over status for two years thank you
representative Edwards has a question
thank you Mr chair you know I think the
legislature needs to always remain
Vigilant to and jealous of our power of
the purse and so in this third bullet
where you say we could either say yes or
no to the agreement it seems to me like
there's probably a third way I want to
run by you uh what what if we just said
hey there's not enough money here's five
percent not ten percent and you don't
have to use it for this if you don't
want to or not but but this is what
we're going to appropriate so
the um the the agreement a collective
bargaining agreement is an agreement
between both parties on a multitude of a
multitude of items and and the
bargaining team on it on the one hand
um which is which is acting on behalf of
the governor the governor signs and the
sca president signs for example on the
sca contract
is a contract on a on a multitude of
items and in theory uh I think legally
the items are are of a whole
um in theory someone would say you know
we we agreed to ten not nine or or we
agreed to 10 not 11 depending on your
perspective based on this and this and
this and if the whole package isn't
there then we would have to negotiate
the whole package so in terms of
partially funding
um the the effect of partially funding
would be to set aside money in the
budget to fund a future collective
bargaining agreement
um as opposed to partially fund this
agreement so this agreement in because
of lack of funding it's a discussion you
probably ought to also have with the
AG's office and I know the AG's office
has sent you a document
um on this but
um the collecting of uh the bargaining
agreement is done and has to be
renegotiated you would be on behalf of
the legislature saying this is the limit
with which we would fund which has
sometimes happened in the past if you
decide to partially fund cost items in a
document one of the things I would
suggest is that we have a conversation
about that because in the you know for
for example one year a few years back
the legislature partially funded only
the general fund portions of an
agreement which meant that if you were
an employee who was not generally funded
for example which is the most of our
employees Highway funded turnpike-funded
partially federally funded I want to let
you know you answered my question thank
you thank you
so how much so why 10 and how much is
inflation eroded wages if you look at
page five
which oddly does have a page number as
opposed to four that's odd
um
so uh historically the you know the cost
of living agreements have have typically
kept pace with wages and only not over
the last five years and I have I have
data here just to
um
so I did the data once a long time ago
to amuse myself because I this is what I
do
um and uh but if you look at it from 93
to 98 the cumulative colas and inflation
were roughly the same from 98 to 2018
and those are picked because they're
round number periods it's about the same
if you want to look at 15 years instead
of 10 they're about the same we kept up
historically the state has kept up
inflation has been difficult over the
last five years as people are aware in a
lot of areas and so while inflation has
been about 20 percent uh coal is have
been above five and I think that's
um probably not speaking for the
bargaining committee the source of those
numbers with with a 10 and a two we will
we will not quite but almost catch up
with inflation but not quite
so that's the bargaining agreements
question representative McGuire thank
you Mr chairman thank you commissioner
um is your inflation column CPI
inflation yes I'm sorry it's CPI thank
you
it's um it's CPI downloaded from the BLS
website non-seasonably adjusted if
you're if you really want to try to
replicate
but I can send you the table follow up
yeah I discovered fairly recently
looking at much longer terms that
inflation in wages is quite different
than inflation in things and so it's
possible that CPI is not the appropriate
comparison
thank you I think there are multiple
things to use but historically the
when it's discussed in bargaining I
think they use CPI because it's a
measure of what theoretically the wages
can buy
and if you've been to Market Basket
lately which is a wonderful store but um
their prices seem to be going up
so
that's a thing okay
if there are no other questions on that
the executive branch job classification
system
um what is a job classification system a
job classification system is designed to
provide an objective and Equitable
process to group job duties and
responsibilities it's just a definition
I think people sort of understand that
large employers uh almost all public
entities and almost uh and most large
employers depending on the size use some
sort of a classification system
to to allocate jobs and the ideas is
Broad Equity
a classification system is meant to
promote parity and titles and
responsibilities to have consistent job
levels and then salary ranges that are
determined by identified rating factors
I happen to list here what our current
system identifies as rating factors
know-how scope and effect complexity
work environment communication
independent action this is something
rating factors is something we've used
since 19
1950 when the when the three disparate
systems were merged into one in in sherm
Adamsville if you will and it's
something that I think this dates back
to the
Philadelphia Rapid Transit company in
the 1890s if you really want to look it
up but that but that's the point we have
a system where every job in the state is
allocated and is placed in a spot in a
giant grid our grid happens to have 35
labor grades and nine steps when
everything is plopped somewhere under
the grid when you look at your job and
say what do you do exactly okay this and
this and and in order to make a
comparative assessment rather than
saying
um well geez I like him so why don't we
make him a labor grade 16 and you not so
much so you're a 12. um we look at it
and say what's the position what are the
duties and how do and we uh and we uh
Factor them in and it produces a number
that comes out of
this is similar to how um
unclassified jobs are measured by the
hey now corn fairy group through the
jcec process
so reforming the classification system
there are a couple things to say I mean
first of all the fact that reform is
necessary is something people talked
about for 50 years right and and those
of you who've been around for a couple
of years will remember the mid 90s there
was a winter commission which was a
National Group
I think headed by the former Governor
Moses's Mississippi or Missouri
something that begins with Miss
um and uh around the same time there was
an Al Gore had a reforming federal
government kind of commission at the
same time
um and one of the things a lot of things
they identified then and we're looking
at now I want to start by saying it's
budget neutral and we say this all the
time both to assure managers and assure
budgeteers and assure employees
everybody will be mapped somewhere in
the new system nobody's salary will go
up or go down as a result of this
everybody will be placed in a new
position but there aren't going to be
quote unquote winners and losers as part
of the process it's an important part of
Reform that you have to start with that
that um
everybody is mapped from a current
position to a new place in a new system
there are a handful of
um
principles that we're trying to use in
the system one is simplification our
system is very complex people have
talked for for at least 30 years about
the enormous number of job
classifications job classification is is
the thing administrator two attorney
four
Etc and there there are 1400 and we're
transitioning from 1400 to 200 we've
actually done this this transition
grouped in 22 major occupational groups
um so we're we're simplifying the system
to make it easier to understand for
everybody inside and outside
standardization our system is New
Hampshire specific everything is New
Hampshire specific we used to have a job
title called administrator to the
Personnel appeals board there are lots
of those everywhere in the country
because we have a Personnel appeals
board other people don't
um so we're using nationally Norm groups
the national standards that are done
routinely and regularly by the by the
feds are called standard occupational
classifications you'll sometimes hear
people talk about sock
and the advantage of the Sox is that
they link to publicly available and
regularly updated employment data
um things about positions things about
vacancies things about
compensation so that there is publicly
available data we link to because we use
nationally normed nationally
standardized things we can link to them
we don't have to guess one of the things
people know is that every time the state
does a classification study which you
know most recently we did based on the
2019 system we spend an enormous amount
of time hiring a consultant to look at
things and say who do we compare this
person to who do we compare this person
to and and how does that look like we'll
have nationally Norm data that does that
for us
analysis I talked before about how we do
a factor analysis to rate positions one
of the things that we don't do we do our
ratings on the basis of job content and
job content alone
something like 80 percent of uh groups
that do classification use a combination
of compensation and job content and the
easiest way to describe this is with
nurses you look at nurses based on
jobcon and you're like you do this and
you do this and you do this and you do
that and it factors out in your labor
grade 18. but
there's no earthly way to hire anybody
at that salary because that's not what
nurses make that may be what the job
content proposes but it's not what they
make and so this what we're proposing is
adding a compensation factor to other
job content which is to say that we
um we analyze based on what it would
actually cost to hire people who do that
for a living and so it would be one of
question representative papovichi Miller
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the questions
um I was going to ask when you started
talking about the budget neutral but
then I saw the you know this point on
the slide a bit later and I figured it
fits better here you are saying that
right now with the remapping no employee
salary will change completely understood
but obviously based on the changes in
here we would expect changings in
compensation to occur over the long term
because we would have better data in the
different classifications to adjust
somebody may come in with their current
salary and be at the high end or at the
low end of a range so they would either
move up more slowly or faster depending
on where they are in the new range and
so on would it be fair to say that while
right now it's budget neutral this
reclassification will change you know
compensations over the long term and
that's really part of the you know
design goals it um it could I want to I
want to clarify exactly how though
because I think it's important in the
current in the current system when when
people think that a classification is
inappropriate on the basis of
recruitment or retention our ability to
hire people that salary we do what's
called an enhancement to that
classification not to an individual
position but to entire class of
positions and so what happens is those
items are are done through I mean it's a
process and the governor's office looks
at them and division of personnel looks
at them in the end they go to governor
and Council we currently have something
like 1400 positions across government
where there's an enhancement and it's
done for this process of enhancement
what we're proposing doing here is is
formalizing in the system so there
aren't 1400 one-offs it's hard to
describe something as a one-off when
there are 1400 of them
um and it's it's clearly a flaw for how
you address that not a flaw but a
presumption is that they would be very
rare and they're not very rare so we
would do that in addition to that in our
current system there are two other ways
in which the um
uh the place a position is slotted
happens is it a labor grade 12 is it a
labor grade 26 and how does that work
um if an employee or a or a or a
commissioner or somebody manager
um thinks that uh an employee is not
appropriately classified or a group they
can ask for a reclassification I can
look and I say you know based on what
Cassie does you know we have her
classified as an attorney too it's not
actually what she does she's more like
an administrator for based on this this
and this and we would look at that
it's done often with vacant positions
and it's done less frequently with
filled positions but we would look at it
and uh there's a review process and we
would decide that position is is not
appropriately classified and it should
be it should be X not Y in addition to
that you can do that with an entire
group of positions uh an entire
classification of positions all like
positions across government that's
currently called a reallocation where
you might look at recently for example
people are familiar with this we did
this with state troopers where state
troopers believed based on a variety of
reasons that they were not appropriately
accounted for and there's a lot of
paperwork involved but it's on this
anticipates doing a lot of that work
similarly but doing it more explicitly
as part of a factor analysis rather than
separately thank you I just wanted to
thank you for the high quality and you
know you know how much we like getting
in the weeds when needed it's it was a
good time to do so well I've tried once
in a while
yeah the only other thing I was going to
add to it as the commissioner was
talking about when we have these today
and I think this is a really important
um item to to notice is that agencies
today if they ask for a reallocation of
a group of positions or reality or
reallocation of just one they still need
to fund it within their existing budget
so when you talk about you know over the
long term can things not be budget
neutral we have a process today for pay
to change for a group or an individual
agencies still have to manage within the
budget that's given to them so how do
they fund it through vacancies or other
things that have changed but it's not
that there's an additional appropriation
that comes to them to manage that thank
you
you have further questions
representative hole thank you two
questions
in the reallocation right for a single
position right who is that review
process going before uh there's a
there's a a unit at the division of
personnel okay and then follow-up we
have
um a large number of positions that are
hourly versus salaried within the state
for
all of them men and well there's us
within DHHS one percent or something is
half a percent is is salaried versus
the balance that are hourly
is there has there been any
investigation into like managerial and
higher level people being salaried
versus hourly there's
um
this gets a little too in the in the
Weeds on this people will remember that
in in something like 2015 don't hold me
till that year
um there was a look the federal labor
department looked at some of the way we
paid people and did things we ended up
engaging a company called littler that's
very prominent in employment law to do
on to do a comprehensive audit uh an
audit that I think only doj has a copy
of and it's thousands of pages to talk
about whether some of the things we did
are appropriate or inappropriate and if
you uh compared to the federal flsa law
and in particular as it surrounds exempt
to non-exempt employees and whether the
state is one employer or not one
employer can you work can you work a
second job within the state without it
with it not counting as overtime the
answer is no you can't
um and
um and we had thought the answer before
was yes apparently
um so that so some of it so that some of
that happens
um we've we have considered in fact our
director of personnel for example has a
has a has a thought on how to create a
group of non-exempt
uh salary salaried classified if you
will positions still eligible to join
the union still eligible to
um to be a classified employee but who
would be functionally salaried and not
on salary it's a significant change and
we've had very preliminary discussions
with the governor about it
um and I I think of it as sort of a
second part of the classification reform
I would like to get there because it
you have a you have an accountant making
a hundred and six thousand dollars a
year it's a little goofy that they're a
uh that they're an hourly employee or
that they're paid as if they're an
representative McGuire for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you
commissioner you said there were nine
steps and I'd like to learn a little
more about those does someone in a new
job always start at step one are the
differences from step one to step two
always X percent the same across all
classifications things like that there's
a grid I can actually refer you to the
the pay schedules are all published on
on our website and uh and for the most
part in the collective bargaining
agreements I think there may be some
that are not
um functionally the grid has
um
so there let me let me start a couple
things about the grid the grid has
diagonal Equity so step two of the labor
grade below is the same as step one of
the labor grid above and then you
diagonally progress so it's and it's
about four percent roughly in in terms
of a grid it's not precisely four
percent I think some of that is over
time but generally speaking like if you
draw a diagonal line you can see forty
two thousand six hundred twelve forty
thousand six hundred twelve Etc and it's
why when someone is promoted in the
system they there's a diagonal path that
they take you go you go diagonally to
their new salary and then up one to to
to get them where they were how do
people start is a good question in
theory
in theory you're meant to start at step
one work your career and and at the end
of I think it's 12 years that it would
take you to progress all nine steps the
early steps are one year and the later
steps are two years and the final step
is three years
um and in theory that's how it would
work that that presumes a world in which
people take a job and stay in the same
company for a very very very long time
it's not actually the world we live in
anymore you know my dad worked for
General Motors for 40 years
um uh it's unlikely I'm gonna work for
anybody for 40 years unless I stay in
this job until I'm 100 which seems
unlikely
um be hard to get reappointed I think at
96.
um the um
and it depends on the climate right in
in some when the labor market is is
quite loose
um
it's much easier for us to hire
everybody who applies to Step One when
the labor market is very tight like it
is today the hopes of attracting anybody
and frankly because of where wages are
the hopes of attracting anybody Step One
is difficult I want to hire somebody in
there you know you you already make more
than I could hire you with at step five
so there's a process where you request a
waiver for hiring at a higher step
follow up thank you so so the the the
ten and two percent colas here are
supplemented by annual step increases of
roughly four percent is that right
yes uh although later in your career
it's two years or the final year three
years and of course your step nine
you're just out of luck
and I think the theory behind the two
different things the one is for
uh longevity and experience than the
others for the cost of living as I think
the
a houseman explained to me in the past
how much effect is there on span of
control one person supervises three and
other supervises ten
does that make a difference if you um if
you think about the the rating factors
and I mentioned earlier what some of the
rating factors are the the idea behind
that is to get a job complexity when I
say job content a big piece of that is
complexity and it's it's your impact on
other employees and your impact on the
state Enterprise as a whole and so there
there are ways to look at that and it's
why you know we we come up with Point
totals but there's a subjective quality
to it in in theory somebody who
supervises 10 people is likely going to
have a higher score on that ranking than
somebody who supervises three
um I I don't say that there aren't cases
where the person who supervises three
has a higher rating because of what he
or she is also doing but um but in
theory 10 is likely to yield you more
points if you will than three how did
the national standards evolve
I hope that's not from the feds well um
they it they did evolve from the feds
and if I mean if you look back at the
way the federal government works
um
I mean frankly when we uh when we
developed our system in 1950 there was a
lot of work done we had a consultant I
think from New Jersey
um who was who was very active in the
Council on state governments who had
developed model legislation and
classification reform you know
classification reform you know I said
the thing about Garfield getting killed
right by a disgruntled job seeker and um
and it's what led to you know uh
President Arthur imposing a a civil
service system and then it was the
Social Security amendments in the 30s
Governor Murphy here at the time who
imposed a classification system but in
1950 that you know there's a lot of work
because most states were adopting them
in the 30s and 40s and they wanted to do
something much more scientific if you
look at that legislation there are all
kinds of charts in it and all of that
the same thing happened federally and
they did a lot of work there have been
three or four periods of significant
Personnel reform at the federal level
one was during the Reagan Administration
when when when Don Devine was director
of the office of personnel management
one was during the Clinton
Administration when when Al Gore had a
had a commission which I think was
called something like Reinventing
government and the the
um whether you think
Al Gore is more Progressive than you
would wish or more conservative than you
would wish there's a lot of really good
data in in that many hundreds of pages
of report so they come out of that and
one of the ideas was to create a system
of of measuring things and it's uh it's
both sock and then the onet database
which which helps tell if it's doing a
good job so it did it did come out of
the feds but after significant reform
you certainly study history
I uh I'm trying to learn my job well
it's my goal it's not working every day
um on decisions I'll just close on this
slide
um our idea that has is to have more
information to make more decisions
exactly what that means
um doesn't mean anything will
necessarily be adjusted and it doesn't
mean just because we think you know it's
possible we'll find that the entire
state is eight and a half percent Below
on average below and what some states
that have done things like this
um they'll have like an auditor or
someone like that do a list of positions
that are particularly anomalous and and
work with either the legislature or some
other mechanism to to reform them
so it's it's information with which to
make decisions
okay
moving on to recruitment and retention
um
this is a big challenge for everybody
here right representative Edwards has a
question oh sure uh thank you Mr chair
and thank you Mr Arlington I I just want
to make sure that my big Epiphany during
this briefing is accurate that that
we're sort of burying the lead a little
bit because people keep talking about
the 10 percent the two percent because
the money is so important but it seems
like slide seven under simplification
this is really the headline of what's
going on we have massive
um transition and reform of our personal
classification system that's in that's
in what all of this is an hp2 the the
transition
most of it isn't an hb2 most of it is
um if you think of governance the uh the
division of personnel is tasked with
doing with doing a classification system
okay so you have the authority to redo
the classification system without an
additional legislation and you're
currently undergoing a massive amount of
reclassification work is that accurate
um if it were not budget neutral we
would have a significant
we would have to interact significantly
with the with the house bill one and
house bill 2.
um but that's a piece of it recruitment
and retention
which um so we talked about the 10 which
is a big part of Recruitment and
Retention but um it's worth worthwhile
saying as a preface that in the past the
state was a destination employer Sherry
came up with that phrase which I think
is which I think is right
um a number of employees who are um I
was going to say who are older than I am
but including some who are younger than
I am because I appear to be aging
um well say you hear people talk all the
time my goal was to get into the state
system and you know my my father always
told me that that that's where you need
to do you need to try to get into the
state system and so it's a good place to
be and and it's been like that for a
long time and there are a number of
employees who want to who want to work
here want to both start and end their
career here
um but it's there are fewer and far
between times really have changed people
don't work at General Motors for 50
years people don't work in a lot of
places for 50 years
what we have to do is continually
realign our policies to actively draw
candidates to the state it's what we
look at and it's what we do how do we
attract talent to the state the state is
the state is not just an employer it's
not just somebody who has people on
payroll it's it the state has lots and
lots of people on payroll doing
um doing enormous things that the entire
working for the people of the State of
New Hampshire that they rely on and and
there's a lot of work and there's a lot
of interaction with with with lawmakers
and other policy makers to ensure that
things happen that ensure that things
happen in a transparent way to ensure
that that policies are being followed
it's a it's a privilege but an enormous
responsibility and
um and to do that we have to we have to
attract good talent to the state I think
you know this committee more than most
sees the results of that when um when we
have good people very good things happen
when we don't they don't so there are a
lot of things that we do and so
um
the first thing I'm going to mention is
my favorite thing because this is my
idea and I fought very hard for this
which is to eliminate the the barrier
dismissed by degrees as the academic
research on this where you create
artificial employment barriers to to
um well to hire you you create oh if you
have a degree if you don't have a ba you
can't possibly have this job I don't
care if you have 20 years of experience
you didn't actually complete your you
complete your degree so we allow
experience and education to be to be
supplemented with each other this is a
significant reform that I think other
states are now following as well we're
very very happy about this and and it
allows us to attract Talent we might not
otherwise have been able to talent and
to to attract and to Reign repay retain
people we might not otherwise be able to
retain based upon their ability to do
the job as opposed to having having
taken the requisite number of English
literature courses
um we're we uh we see increasing use of
promotional pass I think the new system
will allow for more proportional paths
and one way to think about this is this
we have something like 66 different
promotional paths in state government
right now but think of it as a as a bank
examiner Bank examiner one two three
four somebody gets better and better at
their job and they rise in in that in
that path they're promoted within their
position
um they gain the experience to do a
better job and they don't have to leave
to increase their compensation they can
stay here and do so we established a
Statewide recruitment unit which is arpa
funded but to consult with and assist
every agency to identify obstacles and
help agencies and hiring managers
improve hiring practices one of the
obstacles in hiring is that hiring
managers are managers they're not hiring
managers they weren't trained we didn't
hire them because of their ability to
hire we hired them because of their
ability as an accountant as an engineer
as an attorney as an administrator and
yet they're also being asked to do
hiring which is any manager would tell
you the biggest obstacle is hiring to
hiring is that I have to do my job and
hire on the side and so what we've done
is try to identify best practices and
improve things and look at things you've
got 162 people who've waited more than
30 days to be contacted after they've
applied for the job that's not working
in this climate none of those people are
going to work for you because they all
took another job already and so we work
with them and identify as ways ways to
do that I think that's going very well
um we're going to enhance the state's
online presence for recruitment we've
done some of this in the past
particularly with indeed but there are a
bunch of things some of which I am very
familiar with some of which I'm not I
never heard of handshake before but
apparently people who look for work have
heard of handshake before and know a
great deal about it
um and the idea is to go to people where
they are not the old-fashioned State
Methodist that you put if you posted
they will come
you post a job people come see it that's
just not how it works and then they're
the arpa funded Recruitment and
Retention incentives which which I think
for the agencies that received them were
found to be beneficial I would hasten to
add though that very very few people
um in the
percentage basis had access to those
um retention bonuses so it didn't
necessarily affect them
Christian representative Campbells thank
you Mr chair do you promote the quality
of life in New Hampshire to do you have
programs like that to try to get people
from out of state to come here I I don't
want to say that we have a formal
promotion of the quality of life program
it's not like it's not like it's a
separate thing but I think that when
we're recruiting candidates
um
we talk about it a lot and I use as an
example like this committee knows that
that for our department I do a final
interview on everybody we hire and it's
you know
um you know more than 100 people a year
and I would say about half of them are
from are were born in New Hampshire and
half of them came to New Hampshire from
somewhere else including me
um and
the quality of life in New Hampshire is
an enormous attraction to a job here and
it and you know I don't want to I don't
want to second-guess that that's a
that's a big thing I think New Hampshire
itself is a great place to go and we
want people who have decided to go here
to um
um to also want to work for the state as
well
we have further questions one from
representative Wallner then one from
representative emmerich
thank you
uh could you talk a little bit about the
arpa incentives that we were able to
give
specifically around what types of jobs
um received those incentives and sort of
what the range of the incentives were
um Sherry actually has a list which
thank God because I didn't bring one
with me
um but it's I want to as a big picture
item they tended to be mostly jobs at 24
7 facilities if you think of Corrections
Veterans Home New Hampshire hospital Etc
and not for
um
for the most part not for
most employees do you want to hit what
they are sure so I can provide more
detail because I do have a pretty good
handout that has information on it but
just to give you a sense of a few things
one of the early on incentive programs
um as the commissioner mentioned was
Direct Care institutional so think of
Veterans Home
safety Corrections New Hampshire
hospital glencliffe a lot of that was if
you work directly with clients or I
should say with with patients or
residents that was a two thousand dollar
one-time payment for full-time part-time
was 500 there was some parameters in
terms of timing in terms of number of
them we can send the committee uh Sherry
as a summary sheet which we can share
with the committee so just to give you
some some ranges so that you know around
1300 individuals receive that then we
had anything from and I think of that
more as retention you had a it's an
existing employee but then there was
also ones that were
um I'll call them signing bonuses to try
to attract a new hire so Corrections on
correctional officers and Troopers so
think of sworn officers in both of those
agencies they had ten thousand dollar
signing bonuses
that was um not as large of numbers
there was around 15 new hires in each of
those
so a smaller category there also for
safety and Corrections you had a a bonus
somebody pick up the flag
um
okay hang on my eyesight isn't what it
once was uh employee retention
incentives at the veterans some for
non-direct care workers one-time payment
of two thousand dollars full time
safety retention incentives to full-time
State and police fire and safety sworn
personnel
safety recruitment incentive to new
full-time
State personnel
the retention was five thousand the new
is ten thousand Corrections retention
incentives to existing full-time sworn
correction Personnel five thousand
Corrections recruitment incentives to
new full-time sworn Correctional
Personnel ten thousand
and then Transportation had a had a
winter maintenance thing if you agreed
to
uh be part of the winter maintenance
on call for that um it's twenty five
hundred dollars which I gather
was very helpful for them in the winter
so that's the big stuff what period do
you have to work to qualify for the sign
in bonus I mean you can't sign in get
the bonus and leave in six months no but
I think it was six months it wasn't it
wasn't you just get it but I think it's
six months that you had to stay I can
okay
I think we lost Sherry
he canceled his question
oh good okay
representative Edwards has one
thank you I want to come back to
representative hole's question
um I think one of the things that
triggered division three wanting to have
this conversation with you it was the
observation that
DHHS only has two percent three percent
of their total Workforce in a salaried
position
and that just seems odd given everyone's
experience with the commercial corporate
world that's a very very very low
percentage and I know you answered this
in part but what I was looking to hear
is
um to what extent does the department
control its own destiny uh to what
extent can it be initiating
a job relook for positions that really
ought to be salaried and are currently
listed as hourly
they don't we live in a union
environment so they don't I mean the
short answer is they don't control their
own destiny at all
um
to back up a step there are something
like across state government 384-ish
positions don't hold me to that but I
think it's the right number that are
unclassified and historically those were
meant to only be the division head and
the deputy in the division so in 1950
there were like 45 and or something like
that and over time it increased HHS in
the mid 90s when Terry Morton was
commissioner established a set of
positions something like 90 where he
received permission in the legislature
to convert 95 positions forcibly
from classified to unclassified
positions with a
with a set of rules around them that's
the only time that's really happened
typically positions that are converted
are converted one off by the legislature
they can only be converted in a piece of
legislation or established unclassified
in a piece of legislation we currently
exist in a world where
um
almost all of the the Civil Service of
the State of New Hampshire is is paid as
if they're hourly and I use that
phrasing because I think that doj likes
that because we we we're not a hundred
percent compliant exactly necessarily
with flsa
um
to to take a bunch of those positions
the let's just say for the sake of
argument the the highest labor grade
positions and to turn them or the or the
most managerial positions and to turn
them into salaried positions would
require a negotiation with the Union
debate which Union depending on which
agency you're talking about with HHS it
would be with the sea and so that would
require because we're because we're a
you know a union shop if you will it
would require some discussion with the
sea and would have to be bargained So to
that extent they do not control their
own destiny in that respect
representative McGuire for a question
thank you Mr chairman so retention is
extremely important
um we found out recently in discussion
with your office that fewer than 50
percent of group one state employees
reach their 10th anniversary right so so
get ever get vested right I mean so this
is a big problem can you develop some
performance metrics so that we can know
over time whether this is getting better
or worse
and especially this could be a societal
sort of issue right I mean it could be
younger people have different ideas of
long-term employment versus others you
know older people things like that so
um I think we need some kind of metrics
to say we're doing better we're doing
worse Etc yeah we uh so so we track as
people probably know the division of
personnel publishes an annual report
which is mostly a statistical report
um and it it uh they exist on our
website going back to 2003
um and I'm sure there's hard copies
longer ago than that not that anybody
wants them but um that report has always
had in it um a list of separations from
State service and one of the metrics
that they check on it is is separations
over time which is why we had that
discussion about about 50 percent
um what we can do what we will do
frankly whether we decide to or not
we're just we'll track that every year
on sort of an annualized basis on where
they are I think your your point about
societal change though is important I I
people
people expect to look I I think if you
were to talk to the average 35 year old
let's say he or she has his resume
perpetually updated
and keeps an updated copy of their
resume on their computer and updates at
every every
um so like six years ago the governor
decided to nominate me for
um in my current position and somebody
said to me I need a I need a resume
and I said are you sure because I don't
I hadn't done a resume in in almost 20
years and I didn't have one I went I
went and found one in an old version of
Microsoft Works and uh just to give you
an idea and it didn't have like my last
two or three positions and the one
person who I will argue was younger than
I am said what are you kidding me you
should have your resume should be
updated every time you get a promotion
change jobs whatever how do you not have
one on your I'm like I don't know I just
didn't but I think it I think it really
is a generational thing where where I
suspect if I surveyed people who who
work in our agency that probably
everybody under the age of
40 anyway has a resume on their on their
home computer and and
I think that's probably not going to get
better
representative Mooney for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here on the other end of the
hiring Spectrum I'm curious is there an
average retirement age for state
employees
I don't know that we have an average
um I I would say this to the extent that
there is it's increasing from in terms
of retirement retirement
um the uh changes over the last about 10
years have affected the number of years
you have to say to qualify for retiree
Health which for
current workers is more like 20 instead
of 10 means people are more like more
more likely to work until they're 65.
um the uh the cost of Health Care drives
a lot of those decisions as as anybody
who is um at or near retirement age is
thinking about how much health care is
going to cost
um when I was 25 I didn't care how much
health care it costs at all and that
seems to have changed in my life but um
the cost of
um the premium cost of retired Health if
you're under 65 is significantly higher
than it was 10 years ago so we're seeing
more and more people stay until 65. but
I think 65 is still one of those
psychological things Social Security age
for people in their 50s is probably 67
normal social security age but
nonetheless 65 is when you get Medicare
and I think people look at that and it
represent representative Murray for a
question
[Music]
surprised at some of this just coming
out of my own experience
uh I let me put the question this way
would people
would you find that you might lose
someone's interest in a job because it's
an hourly position as opposed to a
salaried position
I think the opposite is true
um oddly I think that um in terms of
conversion we've talked a lot about
conversion because I because I agree
that we should have
um uh salary classified band of
positions but today for most of those
positions you know most of the state is
a 37.5
hour work week and if you work a 38th
hour we must under flsa pay you extra
for it
so in terms of
um
doing that if I convert you from hourly
to salary one of the questions you ask
yourself is well if I'm averaging eight
hours of overtime
um what are you paying me now and one of
the things you would have to do because
you would you would naturally people who
are in a flsa salary category are going
to work something like 40 to 50 hours a
week and so you would have to convert
their salary
from 37.5 to 40 and then make that your
new salary base and so that becomes an
issue but I don't think we're losing
thank you again
um just so that I'm clear again and
again I'm coming from a different
tradition what you refer to as
promotional pass what I possibly
interpret that as Merit increases
because when you're looking at the
salaried position
and you're going above and beyond you
know the 80 hour week there there is
compensation for that and it's can be
you know more significant in what states
would ever go for but
um
is that promotional path is your concept
of Merit increases it's not
um the difference is
um
Merit increases tend to be on the basis
of some sort of judgment that's made by
a
judgment made by a manager somebody
decides there's somebody who's in charge
of deciding how much you get and how
much you get and how much you get and
whether you get something or whether you
don't get something in in the state
system and and again we're not we're
both a civil service system and a
unionized system
um everything is done by rule and and
what you would have to do is establish
um specific
um objective criteria on the basis of
which somebody would go from uh from a
CPS W1 to a CPS W2 you received this you
did this and it's not on the basis of of
a judgment call on the basis of a
supervisor follow-up thank you last one
so if you're really really good at what
you do how are you compensated how do
you how do you express to the person
that they're doing an absolutely
fabulous job
um verbally
um
you do everything you can it's a no it's
a it's actually a really good question
that not financially
um the the system does not allow and
again you know it's a it's a um a system
of rules and a system of uh of a Union
contract and that there's there's
nothing specifically designed for that
it means that if you're a manager and
you're trying to retain uh retain Talent
it's something I think about almost
literally every day
um one of the things that you have to do
is is use
you know non-financial cues and
appreciations and and and do your best
not to be a jerk
and that's a big thing
I mean I it's it sounds flipping right
but not being a jerk is remarkably
important
we'll always quote you on that
representative papovichi Mueller for a
question thank you Mr chair and my
question is on Autumn time but just as a
quick side note on what representative
Murray was talking about this has been
one of my frustrations in my you know
three negotiations with public sector
units that I've been in in New Hampshire
that
they seem to be very resistant to the
concept of any form of Merit pay but
this is something that obviously will
have to be dealt with with any
individual contract negotiation and so
on my question was based on the fact
that I used to work for the town of
Windham and
um we had made certain changes in your
time policy that led from us being
overly generous to some would say a bit
overly less than generous
how how do you feel the state policies
on you know time offer and time vacation
and so on are in terms of our ability to
uh you know attract and retain employees
I I would start by saying that if you
used to work for the town of Windham I'd
want to thank you because we stole one
of your best employees and made her our
comptroller
um and somebody to whom I am every day
trying to offer
non-financial cues to keep her from
leaving
um so that's something
um are we generous are we not generous I
I would say this on on on wages the
state does not keep up well and I think
everybody knows that on just in terms of
the actual salary or wage compensation
we do not necessarily keep up well we
have extraordinary benefits and I'm not
saying that just because it's my
department that administers the health
benefit package but we have a very good
very well administered and a very
um an above average health care plan and
it means if you're an employee for whom
Health Care is important if I'm honest
that tends to be older not younger right
um that's an advantage in terms of time
off I think we have a generous time off
policy we are our time off if you
compare us to other public sector
employers cities sounds counties Etc it
may not be as generous as um as some
towns tend to do better than the state
does
um but if you compare us to the the
private sector we are generous this is a
this came up in our comp study
um they're they're generous we have we
have Personnel policies that
um basically keep employ keep Managers
from
not letting you take your time off I
mean there are obviously some some
things you have to do but if you earn
your time off you're entitled to take it
and and I think we stick with that and I
think in that respect I think it's
actually one of the advantages that
attracts you to the state is work-life
balance thank you and just for the
record uh you guys making Dana an offer
she couldn't refuse was a spectacularly
wise decision thank you that's we agree
okay members we're about to wrap this up
uh representative Hull for a question
thank you chairman as a follow-up to
both Edwards and Murray I guess
um
if you have an employee and you want to
do more than quote not be a jerk unquote
and
um
and there's an interest on the part of
the employee
at becoming salary right contrary to the
data you just share they that's that's
an interest as opposed to hourly
um
you're still going back to the union
even for a one-off to make a change or
is this only when you're trying to do a
reclassification of it well no you to
to change the terms and conditions of
employment in a in a union situation you
have to negotiate with the Union that's
that's just a thing and it's and it's
not about whether whether we agree or
don't agree it's not about whether
whether everybody's on board with it
it's that um
it's that it's a requirement of the of
the structure the fact that we are uh
organized as a collective bargaining
unit that we have to do that there are
in terms of one-offs there are
occasional changes in the legislature is
familiar with this where a position here
or a position there our our Chief
Financial Officer for example used to be
a classified position and it is not that
those changes have to go through a um
um go through legislation and as part of
that process frankly you know and I
think part of that is to allow the
employee a chance to object but in terms
of uh you know if you and I agree and
you say just pay me salary well our
thank you what we haven't the only last
slide was on the hiring process because
I know people talked about it and there
was there was a great deal of
information that was presented to the
division three a few weeks ago that
wasn't entirely in every particular
strictly speaking correct
um and so I uh I I mentioned that in
case the committee wanted to talk about
that we uh you know we make have made a
lot of improvements over the last three
or four years until the hiring process
in terms of streamlining it and making
it easier to understand and more
accessible we have a long way to go in
this respect everybody has a long way to
go in this respect
um and a significant change will include
the next generation of the state CRP but
I would just mention a couple things
there were some discussion that perhaps
if you apply for a job on indeed it
doesn't go to the job on the state's
website that's incorrect something I
actually looked at myself directly with
my staff we went on the internet went to
indeed and occasionally you'll hear
things from employees who've not
actually done a task themselves and will
have heard something from somebody else
that's not strictly speaking correct and
so I wanted to bring that up in addition
in addition people have talked about how
perhaps you have to post a job using
some some of the archaic classification
titles that hasn't been true in decades
and uh and almost every agency in the
state does not do that because it's much
easier to hire a vendor contract manager
than it is to hire an administrator too
and if you're actually posting a job
that says administrator two you're
making a mistake and so we we do a lot
in that respect to try to and we try to
work with agencies this is actually one
of the goals of the recruitment unit
because even within agencies there are
some people who are particularly good at
at figuring out how to hire a position
well and there's some people who are who
are less and our idea is to try to use
you know anything the Department of
Labor learns to help the department of
insurance and anything the Department of
Insurance learns to help the Department
of Employment Security there are 42
state agencies depending a little bit on
how you count and we our goal is to help
all of them in every respect because
they're all important
but happy to answer any questions on any
of that or anything else thank you one
of the things that uh I think we've
observed that said on the finance
committee both of your deputies we have
seen in other agencies and obviously
that's that's a way we also see a
constant change in LBA people that get
trained and then move on to other
agencies and we forever see them coming
back and other roles always dealing with
Finance of course as your deputies do
but it is it is a wide open I guess it
enables people to shift from one job
within state to another fairly easily
without a lot of you know problems and
saying well you haven't been you haven't
filled a full year yet or any of that
stuff you can move fairly easily which
seems to be more uh help in being
flexible in the job so I think it's
actually very important for the state
system to allow people to move from
agency to agency it creates an enormous
situation it it happens that the two of
them both men are a great deal of time
at HHS but and this committee's seen
them over many years in many capacities
but um
I would I would say this that I am I
benefit from having
great employees one of whom we used to
work in a town of Wyndham two of whom
used to work at HHS but otherwise you'd
have to rely upon my judgment rather
than theirs and you are much better off
relying on their judgment than mine and
one of the things we saw for years is
not every agency has a deep bench so
that you've got people lined up to
replace as as people move up and and
many agencies don't have that especially
if they're not dealing much with finance
and they have one Finance Financial
person where you're going to get that
replacement from obviously somewhere
else in the state government so I'm glad
we have that flexibility because it
seems to work out any other questions
from the members
seeing none thank you very much for this
excellent presentation very enlightening
and I can't believe how much you dig
into history
happy to be here anytime thank you all
right we'll close that hearing
and we next are going to hearing on HB
49a and I guess
representative Edwards and perhaps
representative Lynn are going to make
presentations
I'm not sure of the right order to do
this Mr chair I I have I have two
amendments we can discuss uh either but
maybe it would be better to start with a
discussion on uh zero seven three eight
that's right so we have we have
something else representative Earth
there are two
all right Mary Jane would you go to the
mic
we have
um three Democrats who are not here
today and Connie Lane who uh
representative Lane and representative
Schultz are going to set in for them
thank you
so you have two of the two or three
Replacements I have two of three yes
thank you
all right representative Edwards
continue
uh yes sir I would like to move
consideration on amendment to House Bill
202-30738 Hotel it's a relatively short
bill that focuses strictly on the
financial aspects of the sununu
replacement as well as
um making sure that we prioritize arpa
money and we begin to go get a
contractor
all right I guess we're all getting
distributed that Amendment thank you
all right emotion and a second to accept
this is just a work session so it's at
best it's going to be a
struggle
I'll wait for people to look over the
amendment is that all right sir
certainly
all right why don't we discuss the
changes to the original Bill all right
thank you uh just a little bit of
History
um the sununu replacement Center has
been an ongoing issue for a couple of
years at least and
um in the current session uh the Senate
uh passed sb1 24 to nothing sb1 had an
approach appropriation in it had a lot
of detail about what the sununu
replacement Center how it should look
and feel from an operations perspective
how it should be co-located and leverage
shared facilities and the like and
when it came over to the house the house
was not able to
pass sb1 I was
reminded oftentimes during that effort
that that
we are a finance committee we are not a
policy committee and that sb1 had policy
issues in it that was greater than what
our committee ought to be looking at so
we did pass some of sb1 on a very fast
timeline to keep the facility from
closing prematurely on one March we did
appropriate some money we did
appropriate some money for operations
and for
the ability to go do a site selection
process we created a committee or
commissioned to work with the local
community so I think we did maybe 15 to
20 percent of sb1 what it wanted to do
and but we we left some major parts
laying on the ground and one of the
major parts was we did not appropriate
the construction
and we did not tie up the Gopher and
arpa money what this bill does is it
keeps finance and finances Lane and just
deals with those two aspects of the
further questions from committee members
representative Earth
thank you chair could you just so when
we had a meeting of divisions
three and one a few weeks back
and put Fourth Amendment this is not
that Amendment correct
this this is not I started with this
because there was a typo in the
amendment you're referring to and that I
think is uh now available but
nevertheless logically I thought it was
be better today since this is a work
session to build up from Ground Zero
you're right division one and three did
on a ten to five vote pass a version of
an amendment
so
I'm just trying to understand how this
amendment relates to that Amendment this
is a different Amendment this is an
amendment that only deals with the
finance aspects division two has not
heard any of this yet this is just the
financial consequences of us trying to
complete our work on the sununu
replacement Center
if you would if you would prefer
here's my question it looks at this in
some stuff in here that also was in
there is that just a misunderstanding in
my part like the numbers the 21.6
million
you know I don't remember exactly the
extent to which the numbers are the same
I think that the 21.6 million dollar
number has been floating around for a
while so if it's the same number from
what division one and three did I I that
would make sense to me I think that's
where we were there's been so many
amendments on this representative Earth
that I can't remember everything that
we've talked about okay and when we
talked about it
so are we going to see that one as well
or not going to see that I I think we
can see that one this is this is uh
we're having a discussion on on what
this is and this is the Bare Bones
nothing but Finance version of an
amendment that would I think complete
The house's work in 2023 on the sununu
replacement Center we can we can do more
representative
representative Griffin for a question
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question representative
um is this still an 18 bed facility
yeah
it it it would not change what's in
what's in sb1 in sp1 it it says that the
site selection should be looking at two
options it should be looking at an
option that is a six to twelve facility
or another option that uh staffs at as
though the residents were at 12
operationally staff at 12 but with a
physical capacity at 18. so so that's a
now I went back and looked at uh the
women's prison
it costs 38 million dollars
it serviced uh
224 beds I believe
that comes out to about a hundred and
seventy thousand dollars a bed
this comes out to something over a
million dollars a bit
and I just there's no way in my mind I
can justify the kind of money that's
that's being put on the table here thank
you
representative Edwards I I think that's
a that's a fine Financial observation I
would just you know point out just a few
things that would bear on on your
observation one is that
um the uh the bonding of the woman's
women's prison took place a number of
years ago and just even in the last
couple of years we've seen a lot of
inflation
um also this is intentionally explicitly
not a prison this is uh a continuation
of the juvenile
mental health and Behavioral Health
System the the the point of this
facility is not incarceration it's to
get away from an incarceration model and
instead replace it with a
trauma-informed uh I I keep forgetting
the terminology but basically being
sensitive to the fact that these kids
probably need some mental Health
counseling more than they need to be in
a prison environment so we're building
something different than what you're
representative Miller and then
representative Hull
thank you Mr chair having you know just
recently visited the current facilities
I just wanted to say I cannot comment on
whether the amount of dollars is right
or not that will take a much deeper dive
but I would say that I I don't think we
should compare this with again pure uh
incarceration facilities because this
Center the whole route of the problems
was that it was originally treated as
just incarceration and it created a lot
of issues there is much more that we
need to do for the very few miners that
will end up in those places they need
very Specialized Care and again while I
cannot comment on whether this amount is
appropriate or not I would urge us to
use a different Baseline because it is a
very different type of facility thank
you
thank you Mr chair I apologize I stepped
out so you may have covered this this is
a work session only there's a plan I
believe to have a follow-up work session
an executive session
that's true and then secondly in terms
of germanness on amendments right
because we're back to the original Bill
I know
that one of the Amendments that's been
drafted has been looked at and has been
ruled effectively non-germaine we'll
have a hearing on that
when do we know where that line is
between a bill that was relative to
propose Pro to postponing the closure of
the sununu center to one that is now
discussing finances or any other changes
of law
do we have to have all of these go
through that hearing next week as
non-germaine since the dates already
we will have to determine on on the
amendment after the committee hears it
whether it's non-germaine or not an
appropriate to the the line of
questioning we've had we obviously had
to do something or the sonuna Senate
would be closed by now then we also have
to follow up on the financing of the
replacement and obviously this this
gopher money came available but it had a
deadline so there's some urgency on
operating on on that deadline and
getting make
certain that we have the finance lined
up and we're ready to construct
we will leave it up to Public Works to
how efficient or how how well designed
it is and we don't have that design yet
so those are the things we have to look
at but if
if we decide it's germane after we've
heard that the next Amendment at the at
the next public hearing then we may
incorporate it otherwise we may go ahead
with what we already have before us okay
so but we've got to get something done
representative thank you thank you for
taking my question I'm just curious I'm
trying to remember through the details
of Senate bill one and then taking this
amendment into account
if representative Edwards could clarify
if
this amendment also moves through who
would then be the decision maker for
both the site and the ultimate
um
size of the facility or is that
something that would be coming down the
road
uh thank you for the question if you if
you when you look at Amendment
0738 before you if you look at the end
of uh line 10 uh reading on to line 12.
uh the department may use the final
report of the commission established in
RSA 169 blah blah in order to finalize
the capacity and size selection of the
replacement Center so this moved it in
previous versions that you saw where it
said governor and Council that was being
floated this language came directly from
the governor's office this was their
request for what we do with uh with this
piece of legislation and I throughout
this process I've been trying to figure
out how we can say yes to each other so
I took the governor's requested language
and included in in here thank you I
appreciate the clarification
okay we have two other co-sponsors in
the room and and I'd like to recognize
and see if they have anything they'd
like to add representative Lynn may have
uh thank you Mr chair um and members of
the committee I guess I'm I'm maybe a
little bit at a loss if if you are if
the non-germaine Amendments that you're
talking about discussing at another
at another meeting uh pertain to what
what I've sort of referred to maybe
colloquially as the former House Bill
254 that is dealing with who who can be
committed for what if that's the subject
of the of the non-germaine amendment
then maybe I should wait until to
discuss it later uh but I'm not sure if
that is what you're talking about
that's that's the amendment that the
house clerk has decided was non-germaine
and requested we have a separate hearing
on that so that's what's been scheduled
that that was really the main thing that
I want what I would that I was here to
to sort of talk about
um but and I'm happy to do that you know
at the net whenever you have the next
year thank you representative Earth
when's the when's the date of the
hearing
we're going to get a straw poll on the
acceptance of what we've got so far
and then
once I have that understanding amongst
all of us then we look at the the final
HP 49 will make a decision as to the
germaneness of it by this committee and
then
if that's the instance we'll either use
it and incorporate it and vote on one
time on the bill with all the Amendments
or we will vote on the bill without the
the so-called non-germaine Amendment
which we haven't judged yet to be
non-germaine
representative Erv so I think I think
the question that representative Lynn is
asking is are we talking about the other
Amendment and it sounds like
representative Edwards has one as well
I'll be discussing all these amendments
today are we waiting until after the
public hearing related to the
non-germaine one before we discuss
anything else since we don't have that
Amendment before us that I believe that
uh show you the people here have all
worked hard on we don't have it before
us at this point we do we have it here
well since the clerk has said we need to
have a hearing I think it's more that we
more appropriate that we have the
hearing and let everybody know that may
want to have input and then have have
the discussion of the one that's that's
been told we need to have a separate
hearing for so that's that's what I'd
like to proceed
that that's fine with me Miss Jared I
just I'll I assume they'll be noticing
when the hearing is and I'll I'll appear
there and
um and you know uh that's what I'm fine
do we have a date on that representative
Earth I work for Wednesday
a week from Wednesday
Wednesday
the 15th okay all right time
10 A.M
I'll be there thank you all right and
representative leishman did you want to
comment on this amendment
I do support this amendment
thank you representative walner
I got my question answered I wanted to
know when the non-termaine amendment was
going to be heard I do want I do want to
ask though
it would seem like
we would want to hear the non-germaine
amendment and this one at the work on
this one and the non-germaine amendment
together incorporating it into one one
Amendment and not
a bunch of
a bunch of separate little amendments
how many how many other members would
like to see that other Amendment today
raise your hand
the one that's been judged non-germaine
um
I have it I didn't print out hard copies
because I thought it wouldn't be heard
by the committee until next week but I
can do that and have them available
shortly
just people want to have it to look at
we're not going to discuss it till the
public hearing but so anybody can can
see what's in it and get a chance to
read it because I think it's about five
pages
nine pages so it's fairly it's fairly uh
voluminous
so
um
representative Stringham
yes uh thank you for this amendment
um and for your clarification on the
lines 10 through 12. uh question on on
um on the amount and the timing that
you're putting it in in this year's
budget
um the 21.6 million
um it it uh in in part I thought the the
total need may be less than 21 million
depending on the final design so
um and I believe hb2 has a number less
than 21 I think it's 10 million
appropriated for this purpose so
um uh why should we put 21.6 million out
of this year's budget for this purpose
what do we gain by that rather than
putting it in the next biennium budget
and um uh and any comment on the
differences with hb2 thank you
it might be because of the amount of
money that's available through the
through the federal funding that's
that's going to go away
so represent which you want to add to
that yeah yes sir two things one um this
language also came straight from the
governor's office it's an enhancement of
what we had read previously and it tries
to tighten up the CL and clarify our
desire to have this as much as possible
federally funded to the to the issue of
the 21.6 million estimate Mr ribson is
uh is in the room he he might be a more
authoritative person to speak to that
Mr ribsom is a director ribsum is
recognized
good morning still yes good morning Joe
rubs from director dcyf thank you uh for
hearing from me the 21.6 million dollar
estimate is the estimate that Das Public
Works provided for the cost of building
uh the replacement facility my
understanding is that the thinking
behind the way that the budget in hb2 is
crafted that has 10 million dollars in
general funds the idea was that that
would be I believe in addition to what
was what was anticipated to be 15
million dollars through ARP so that's
gets you actually the 25 million total
that being said 21.6 is the agreed upon
number at this point that um that Public
Works has put forward is the cost for
creating a replacement facility
and my recollection is we had uh Mr
cupper from Public Works saying you
couldn't build an 18 bed for the 15
million so he felt some of that was some
of that estimate was for a 12 million
and he he came before us last week I
believe to say you needed 21 million
representative Edwards you had further
so so my thought on this Mr chairman is
if if we get this version or this amount
out of the house and get some feedback
from the Senate preferably they would
pass it then we could adjust hb2 I think
appropriately to take care of
Representative stringham's observation
that maybe some of this money is being
thank you
further from representative ribsum you
representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman yes Mr Remsen um
at I agree with representative Griffin's
point that this is a very expensive
facility but in my mind the real money
here is the operational money
um if you look at the original House
Bill 49 it allocated
um one and a half million dollars for
um three months of operation so we're
talking about six million dollars a year
for operational expenses is that what
you expect this facility once built to
to cost
so I I don't think
um the the additional appropriation of
1.5 million is not the total cost of
three months of operations at sysc that
was the supplement even worse that was
the supplemental that was needed in
order to to close out the year given the
reduction in
um outside funds that used to come in
through the Vermont contract plus the
extensive overtime that we're paying
right now just to keep the facility
safely operating given the fact that our
Workforce has has essentially been
decimated
um the information that I shared with
division three and I think I have some
copies of in my folder I know Mr Ripple
has was that we were anticipating
somewhere just under three million
dollars a year just in Personnel savings
by being able to have a co-located model
so there are operational savings year
after year by having a co-located model
where we'd be either near in proximity
with New Hampshire hospital or Hampstead
Hospital for the purpose of being able
to share certain types of services and
programming you have more of an
opportunity for shared services at
Hampstead because in addition to kind of
core functions like food laundry Etc you
would also have the potential ability to
share Educational Services and Clinical
Services in a way that New Hampshire
hospital wouldn't offer a shared service
opportunity so um there's that piece of
it then there's the cost of just
maintaining this massive campus with
with buildings that are not in good
shape right would end the size of the
facility itself we spend eight hundred
thousand dollars a year just in
utilities on that campus that that
wouldn't be the same if we were to move
to a smaller facility co-located
elsewhere so there are definitely
operational savings to be realized year
after year by moving to a lake located
model
um
and I do think by any estimate if you're
looking at magnitudes of three plus
million dollars a year in operational
savings that you know the cost of the
facility is going to pay for itself in a
number of years
seeing none
representative Edwards since this is a
work session I I it may have value to go
ahead and bring forward the other more
comprehensive Amendment so that people
can understand that
at least between these two amendments we
have some different kinds of choices to
make there's some similarities but there
are some differences so with with your
permission I'd like to have us bring
forward the Second Amendment
is is that the one that that was
referred to as non-germain or is it
another one you have this is not the
non-germaine one the the non-germaine
one it changes the criminal code this
relationship
okay this this is one that had an
but let's let's hand it out we're for
some reason we're just having an
extremely unusual hard time having OLS
and me communicate on on what words they
ought to be putting we met at nine
o'clock this morning and there's a
second error even though we met in
person
um all right we'll give we'll give Mr
Ripple time to pass it out so everybody
representative hole did you have a
question while this is going on thank
you
um looking at 0738 right lines 11 and
following sorry lines 13 and following
this has to do with whether we can use
arpa funds for any of this I'm not sure
if the committee is aware
um
our neighboring state of Maine is
currently being sued by the ACLU of
Maine for the use of just a mere 1.2
million dollars of arpa funds for the
renovation of a facility we should tread
carefully on this I'm not sure that that
money was being it will be available so
I think the committee should be aware of
that
do you recall the nature of why they're
suing and what they're objecting to in
the use of Opera funds
I can yes I can read the news article
right
um the American Rescue plan was intended
to support local governments and
responding to the impacts of covid-19 on
their communities although Penobscot is
is correct the arpa funds could not be
used to build a new jail it is wrong for
arpa funds to provide a blank check for
all jail Renovations so they're already
clear that it can't be used for a new
jail and this is a juvenile facility not
a jail there are differences but in some
cases there's a lot more similarities
between these I don't want the committee
to blindly believe that we have this
blank check available that we might not
have available so I I want to bring it
to the committee's attention now before
we proceed
I'll ask representative a correct
correction I'll ask director ribson if
he has any knowledge about the arpa
funds and whether or not there'd be any
hey
um I think it was in division three that
we talked about this issue as well I am
certainly not the expert on the on on
the use of our funds what I can tell you
is that this is conversations that have
been had with gopher
um you know for well over a year now
when this was first being thought about
last year and it was an approved expense
through their processes but I think they
would be the ones who'd be best
positioned to go deep on that issue
which as far as you know the question
has been raised and dealt with
yes
um the way that the process works is you
know we put forward what the what the
intended use is they have a legal review
and all types of other things that they
do before they move forward and my
understanding is that that had been done
and that there was funding put aside
specifically for this purpose thank you
representative erf thank you Mr chair
and this is not a question from Mr ribs
and this is just a a point of
information so we have tried and I
personally but also others have to try
to get the legal opinion from gopher
regarding this and we're not
heard from them they also invited to
several of our work sessions and they
haven't shown it that had any of them to
talk about this so we don't really have
a definitive answer to the question
which I think is what representative
is there anyone present that can comment
on the Gopher situation please come
forward
uh good well I guess it's still morning
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Chase Hageman I'm
the deputy director at the governor's
office for emergency relief and Recovery
do you spell your last name
h-a-g-a-m-a-n thank you
uh so I guess I can just jump right in
uh to the question at hand about whether
arpa State fiscal recovery funds could
be used on the facility of this nature
um the gopher's opinion on this based
off of federal guidance is that yes it
can based on the eligibility category
that we would recommend using for those
funds on the facility
the I don't know the nature of the
lawsuit with our neighbors or what
eligibility category the state may have
used for their facility and use of funds
but the eligibility category for
government services is a very broad one
that treasury has given quite a bit of
latitude to states to use on a variety
of types of facilities and and
expenditures and this would this would
qualify for it
thank you represent hole did you have a
question for this gentleman
not at this time thank you
representative erf
could you just provide us that uh
written opinion so we have that for
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chairman
um with with uh with your permission
then I I would like to start a
conversation about uh the Second
2023-0757 hotel that's been handed out
for those people who have looked at uh
sb1 and you start to flip through this
this is going to look extremely and feel
very familiar to you because this is
this is the part of sb1 that we did not
pass when we did our truncated version
to uh for uh for close the closure
so so this uh we'll go ahead and
maintain the whole statement of findings
that has been vetted numerous times it
it goes on to describe who's going to be
responsible for it it goes on to
describe that the facility is going to
be managed
by the department and not be contracted
out it describes on the second page some
of the
characteristics of the facility design
it talks about the facility programming
and and operations
um
so this is this is essentially it talks
about on the bottom page three the
reporting that we're expecting
in other words this is all of the
components of sb1 that we said we didn't
have time to consider last time and this
is our second bite at the Apple
um I I apologize to the committee
because on page
lines 10 through 12. I I thought we had
a very specific conversation this
morning that that language lines 10
through 12 about the governor and
Council was to be removed
and replaced with the phrase that's on
zero seven three eight that phrase being
the department may use the final report
of the commission established in RSA 169
in order to finalize the capacity and
site selection of the replacement Center
that that it was supposed to be there I
don't I don't know why it's not but um
but otherwise this is a pretty good
document I think for conversation it's
it's basically the rest of sb1 it's got
the governor's language in there about
the authority to select a version of the
of the building and it should have Mr Mr
Ripple I'm going to look at you it it it
does have the same language for the the
Gopher money at the last bottom of the
sheet right so we're we're at least in
sync that we got the governor's language
relative to the the arpa money in here
so
um
so so so that is the longer Bill uh I
offered it if the
finance committee had the appetite to
finish the sb1 work
this will get us through all of the sb1
work
the shorter amendment was for those
people who didn't have the appetite to
go through all of that and wanted to see
children and family law involved and
wanted to see perhaps some other
jurisdictions involved the second one is
merely let's do our job and complete the
finance work so so that's that's what
is everyone clear about looking at the
three amendments I'd probably do a straw
vote on each of them the first one is
zero
what's the first one here
all right I guess it's two amendments
we're looking at here
representative Wallner
wouldn't we wait until we had seen the
non-drain amendment at the at the
hearing before we started taking straw
votes I mean it's like people are trying
to
decide which one they prefer or like
which parts of each one so I'm
suggesting that we now have
two amendments before us there's another
one coming I think next Wednesday
and wouldn't we wait and put it all
together once we've seen all the pieces
I'm feeling they're all part of the same
thing
0758 talks about
0738 rather talks about
can we can we adopt the funding while
it's available
then 0757
talks about some of the details of what
is what's going to happen when it's
built so they're all part of the same
thing without one replacing another and
then the other one we'll look at so what
I'd like to do is if everybody's happy
with the funding that we're looking at
here
0738 and and the process we've heard
from the gentleman from gopher and Mr
ribson on how this figure was derived
from it is very expensive granted but we
don't have a lot of choice here and if
if we can get a lot of this money from
the federal government it isn't
something we'd have to incorporate into
hb2 or hb1 so if people are satisfied
with what the the explanation we've
heard I'd like to do the straw vote
first on 0738 so we're satisfied that
there is a source of funds there is a
source of perhaps gopher or arpa funds
that will
supplant some of the
State money
to get this built and it also has a
deadline that we have to be aware of
Representative Hewitt
I'm sorry but I I don't think I'm in a
position to make any judgments on this
um we have a different language in in
two different amendments as an old bill
that is no longer being considered I
guess and then we've got another one
coming
uh we need to be able to put the whole
thing together and see how how it's
going to work and just to say that well
the the uh
the Opera funds would be good or
something else would be good it's not
going to not going to do any good in
terms of deciding what the heck to do I
think that before we take a straw vote
we need to know what the heck we're
going to do in the final analysis and
not uh just take little pieces and put
them down the table and say this is what
we're going to do I can see that as
causing a great deal of commotion once
we get to the point where we've seen all
the moving pots put together
how many agree with that statement by
all right sufficient that we won't do a
straw vote on these we'll wait until
next Wednesday a week from Wednesday
when we'll see the last Amendment where
we'll have Judgment of putting it all
together and I know that Mr Ripple is
we we can hand it out now so people will
have all these pieces together to look
at and and decide whether it all fits
together or not so
representative Edwards so I understand
what we just did but
for somebody who's been pushing this
rock up the hill for two years one thing
that we seem to be able to do every
single time is to find another reason to
delay
it's just the the these two amendments
that I offered today are well within the
defined terrain of everything this house
has seen this year that the Senate voted
on 24 to nothing the non-germaine
amendment that's being brought in at the
11th Hour dealing with the criminal code
by the finance committee is the
exception to the process
um and I'm
fine let's let's wait but uh I I guess
I'm just losing my patience for
um the way in which we find new ways
creative ways to delay the process at
some point we ought to have an honest to
God conversation about what we're
willing to do and do it
representative Hall thank you Mr
chairman it is my understanding that any
deadline regarding use or potential use
of arpa funds is in the December 2025
time frame I may be wrong but there was
a discussion in division three
um
and it has to do right and it's not
something where the additional week of
discussing various options is going to
put that at Jeopardy it's not like we
have to commit to and use these funds by
even the end of April or the end of of
this session right it's about having
turning the keys over to this facility
to a new to DHHS to have as operational
um and then secondly I don't know how if
there's a way I I can Mr Ripple put this
up under the division three or under the
finance so other citizens can see and
weigh in on this if we're gonna have a
public hearing for full transparency I
think it makes sense to be a that this
document be allowed to be visible now
even though it's only going to come up
next week it should be something we can
post as a as a discussion item
under the the LBA
he left the room though I don't see Mr
Ripple here now but we can we can ask
that he do that
I I would ask that um that instead of
posting zero seven five seven that we
know OLS continued the error that we uh
post the correct version of the
amendment when it's available
done
further questions representative Mueller
and then representative McGuire just a
very quick statement I do not think that
I will be comfortable in the next three
weeks looking at any policy decisions on
this
we don't I barely don't see how we'll
have the time to do the state budget let
alone start making complex policy
decisions so as far as I'm concerned I
will look at funding this but I'm not
gonna really spend a lot of time and
effort frankly looking at last minute
policy changes here there are other
committees other places to discuss that
we have enough on our table
thank you representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman just a comment on
zero seven five seven
um on page two where it says the
facility shall be designed to include
all these things
um
some of these things I think may be
taken care of by the co-location with
the other facility in Hampstead and
maybe this should be written in such a
way that the facility and the co-located
um other facilities shall provide these
things you see what I mean because
because like I I could read C and and
possibly G as being things that might be
for two years now I've asked for people
to provide written documentation on what
they'd like to see in this bill and I I
would be happy to take whatever language
you have to offer okay
I'll try to help him yeah
Mr Ripple while you were out it was
asked that you
post this zero seven
five seven on the website and also that
Mr Mr chair if I may to post zero seven
four six on the website and to post zero
seven five seven H as re with the
Amendments that uh representative
Edwards has asked for in section on page
four in section or set lines 10 through
12.
yeah she he wanted that to go back to
where we allow the the um
the agency after the to proceed with the
uh report from the commission
so
all right so I guess it's zero seven
four six we're going to post which isn't
there already in zero seven five seven
after it's corrected
four six I think I mentioned that yes
okay Mr chair representative erf
so just for clarification understand
where
zero seven five seven came from as I
recall when division one and division
three met jointly
um a vote was taking place of some sort
and I'm wondering what was is this what
we voted is this what was voted on that
day or is this something else
this this is 96 of that with the changes
proposed by the governor that I I
referred to earlier about different
language around
um protecting the Gopher money and on
the final who would make the decision so
those two components are different from
the 10-5 straw poll that division one
and three took follow-up
follow-up so and I'll just make a
comment it doesn't need to be a question
but it appears that taking taking that
those changes into this in conjunction
with the earlier Amendment we heard
about the 0738 that if I'm not mistaken
that's basically what division one and
division three looked at and can vote it
out of sort of voted out of whatever
that was a couple weeks ago and just for
information for the committee this new
Amendment zero seven four six is exactly
what came out of
that division one division three meeting
several weeks ago with changes so just
to understand that the basis of zero
seven four six is identical to what the
division and division three division one
and three people looked at with
additional changes to it but in terms of
the underlying everything the money is
back in is in here there's some other
changes about it I guess I won't go into
today we'll wait for the till next week
but you can other than the changes that
are in here is identical to what came
out of division one division three a few
weeks back
clarification on the clarification
on your page six of that Amendment it
the changes of the criminal code are
included there
and and I believe you subsequently had a
conversation with the representative
Lynn who suggested some tweaks to that
language so so while it's very close to
what got discussed in that joint
division one and three work session it's
that is not what I said
what I said was
the basis of zero seven four six is
identical to what was voted out of
division one division three what I see
in these other two pieces
738 and 757 are components of that but
they are also not identical to that
and we sort of touched on some changes
apparently but not everything I thought
we were not yet discussing the seven
four six today because you want to wait
till after the Germaine hearing the
non-germaine hearing so yes you're right
there there are changes in here a number
of them for sure and the I will discuss
those we will discuss those at whatever
representative Hull thank you Mr
chairman
um I appreciate the comments
um from the member from the Gopher
committee is it possible to ask for the
Attorney General to weigh in on use of
arpa funds because at some point if this
state has to defend that this is not
about the go for committee making a
recommendation it truly would be the AG
having to defend that action in court
and knowing of several lawsuits across
the country right now on this I would
want their opinion on this more so than
a committee
I will see if we can get that opinion
I don't think there's anybody here from
the attorney general
no one seems to volunteer that so we'll
representative Hewitt uh I I just want
to add that probably at some point we're
going to come to a conclusion and if we
come to con a conclusion it's going to
be one bill we can't vote to adopt all
of these in all of these amendments and
previous bills that haven't amounted to
a hell of beans we need to have a
comprehensive Bill and it has to be
something that can be enacted one of the
things that I have noticed is that in
terms of the funding there's been
there's been talk around around the
around the uh lob here about
the fact that
I'm thinking in the state either the
Missouri Missouri or Mississippi has
been sued concerning this but they're
talking about the ultimate uh the
ultimate
ability of the state to actually spend
the money one of the things I noticed in
at least one of these amendments is a is
a statement of the money being expended
but if it if it turns out that it can't
be something else is going to happen
that's one of the ways you get around uh
all these uh these lawsuits that are
filed all over the country which which
many of them probably don't have a don't
have a chance in in Hell of getting
getting a
getting a positive result so I think
that we can we can proceed with
analyzing the information we have in
front of us and coming to a conclusion
uh as to what ought to be presented to
the to the to the legislature as a whole
uh rather than just debate amongst the
Amendments such and such Amendment so
and so let's just get out get all our
our eggs in one basket here and decide
what to do and then we can take the
necessary steps to put the the exact
document that the legislature wants out
so that it can be voted on are you
suggesting that we try to have OLS put
it into one document
I was thinking about that actually Mr
chairman
Mr chairs isn't that why we were going
to release the Mr Ripple's reply
what do you think of asking the OLS to
combine the parts of this that are the
same into one Amendment separating it by
section one section two and so on and
then we can vote separately on the
sections
ice
I I think you could definitely do that
I think that would work I'm not sure if
they should all be listed as
non-germaine amendments for the
upcoming hearing next week
I'm really not sure how that would be
noticed but it could definitely be
definitely be done they could be broken
out into individual amendments yeah I
think if if we
it seems to be a a need to see one
document
because Raven go back and forth well
that's the same in this one same in that
one if if they're all if there's
sections that are the similar that can
be combined so we don't have to keep
looking back and forth and we can just
obviously one will say
here's we're going ahead with funding
the second one will will say something
to the effect that you know these are
the things that need to be incorporated
in in the building and the other one
will say here's the things that need to
change in the uh the reasons to uh
incarcerate people so we put them in
like section one section two section
three I would propose that we vote on
them separately and whatever survives
with them with the majority vote will go
forward the ones that do not survive
those sections may be eliminated
so so just to be clear so you you're
requesting only one Amendment but you
want the individual components broken
out separately within that Amendment yes
and things that are common in the
different amendments could be in the
separate sections okay where they're
common
for the representative Earth
so I would just point out
that 746 is that single amendment that
contains everything that's in
the thing that came out of division one
and three
and the these other two pieces are
components of that as well
and then there are changes
and if you do what you just suggested
um I don't think you'll pass anything
out of committee because 746 is intended
to be
a hole that will capture the appropriate
sense of the house as to what the house
believes should be
come
the continuation of the sununu bill and
yes it does go beyond
what was in what came out of division
one and three specifically with regard
to the change of law but that's only a
component of what is in there we passed
a thing called HB 254 out of the house
last year twice
and that is what we've well maybe we
haven't all heard but most of us have
heard that that was what died in
committee last year with the Senate so
for those that haven't heard now you
haven't had that as well
and it's important that it be considered
as a whole that changes to the law in
conjunction with the zenunda center
because the changes to the law relate
directly to the kind of minors that
should be incarcerated well either
detained or committed at the sununa
center so I would suggest if you want to
have two versions
you have 746 as one and that could mean
like the second version and then you go
back to what came out of division what
division division ones and threes and
then have representative Edwards add in
the changes that he put into the two
pieces that he has here so then that's a
unified version
and you had two unified versions to
can both get together with Mr Ripple and
the OLS and try to work this out and
bring us something that will be isolated
because I see there are Parts like
section five in your bill might be
section one in one of the other bills so
I just want to separate them out where
it's very obvious are we approving the
construction are we approving this the
way it's used are we approving who can
go there so I see them as three separate
things
question
Mr chair I I just would want to remind
folks that HP 254 was last term that was
a different house that house has been
dissolved that doesn't exist
the criminal code changes they're being
brought to finance at the 11th Hour have
not been heard anywhere in this house
it's being brought into the finance
committee at the last moment and that's
why this is non-germaine I I I think
given that we have
a budget that we need to do in the next
few weeks that we ought to stick to our
knitting which is let's do the finance
things and either of my amendments will
do the finance things and let and then
we can we can turn the rest of this over
to
criminal and family law they've retained
House Bill 120 and they can
include their consideration on the
criminal code changes in in due course
rather than us trying to jam a
non-germaine Amendment through into a
finance committee
that will be the discussion for a week
representative Hull for a question
thank you Mr chairman so looking at the
various versions in front of us in
particular the section labeled
appropriation
which is Section Five in hold on in 746
and it's Section 1 in 738 and I don't
know where it is in the other one
the language in the appropriation
section changes into representative who
it's come in earlier right about they
may use these funds and if they can't
use type language they should be pulled
from General funds
I'm not the attorney here but whichever
one is the best version of those various
appropriation sections relative to the
management of the arpa funds and I leave
that to people who know the law better
than I do
let's put that in there because it looks
like the latest version references
statute part of sb1 that passed into law
and the older version was in reference
to where we were when we were working on
this a couple weeks ago
I don't know what the right one is but
whatever the appropriate appropriation
language let's get that into this
version
you're all invited to attend with with
Mr Ripple
that want to have some input to OLS
they have very small cubicles but I'm
sure they can make an arrangement maybe
we can meet them somewhere else but to
get something cogent that is separate
sections because I believe there are
agreement on some sections but not all
of them
further
this reminds me of a committee of
conference and I bite my tongue when I
say that but is there a way to have a
a versus B versus C comparison
um Excel file that kind of highlights
the differences between them so we can
track it
Mr Ripple there are multiple amendments
we can do a side by side comparing the
Amendments yes
thank you
further on this question
all right before they work in the
afternoon
division one are you having a meeting
one o'clock for division one and you
work session on the budget in division
one
District Two one o'clock
work session on the budget division
three
uh we're gonna do some of that but we
also have four specific bills that have
been put into the calendar
and you will have they been advertised
that you will meet with them this
afternoon
yes and they're posted very good and I
would just point out that that's at two
o'clock not one that's division three
two o'clock for division three Okay so
if you all want to go and have a meeting
now or or ask Mr Ripple I will try to
call the attorney general and see what I
can get on arpa funds and so on
and enjoy your lunch and uh
thank you for being here look forward to
some clarity on this issue
if it's possible